[Musique]
ce soir si je suis là c'est pour parler
d'un sujet qui me tient vraiment à coeur
et qui saura attirer votre attention car
c'est un sentiment que tout le monde a
déjà ressenti bon j'aurais peut-être pu
vous posez la question d'ailleurs de le
dire quelqu'un dans la salle c'est déjà
senti différent n'hésitez pas à lever la
main ça m'aiderait beaucoup mais
je pense que pour commencer ce serait
bien de définir la différence la
différence c'est toutes ces choses qui
nous rendent unique et qui nous
appartiennent la différence elle est
d'abord physique on la voit avant de la
ressentir mais aussi mentales ou
réfléchir différemment on pense
différemment on perçoit la chose à faire
est différent par culture on est
différent pour des raisons familiales en
fait on est tous différents et on a
plein de différence
et l'idée ce soir c'est de voir toutes
ces différences comme une chance comme
une ressource pas encore assez exploité
comme une pensée évolutive
pour être plus clair ce soir j'essayerai
de partager l'idée que ces choses qui
nous rendent unique et qui nous
appartiennent devrait pas être cachés
laisser abandonner ou détruits au profil
une image de groupe mais au contraire
devraient être utilisés par chacun pour
s'affirmer en tant qu individu à part
entière et c'est quelque chose de
fantastique mais si vous arrivez à vivre
et vous exprimer en accord avec vous
même vous sentirez obligatoirement mieux
pour illustrer la différence j'ai choisi
de parler de quelqu'un qui est différent
comme tout le monde c'est paradoxal mais
surtout de volontaires puisqu'il s'agit
de moi
j'ai redit qu mal et puis je maîtrise
pas beaucoup de mots
alors hors jeu morts
personne n'est surpris malgré
l'avènement des surprises
l album si oui c'est de comprendre
pourquoi je demandais comment cet
étrange
alors des séquelles si nous a expliqué
qu'en fait c'était normal je mords
départ parce que j'avais besoin de
m'exprimer je m'en débarrasse
en fait c'était juste pas m'exprimer
j'ai bien
chacun
ses émotions
et par exemple des parents expriment
leur amour et leur fils
tandis qu'elle est intéressant
g.skill à l'époque
pas le besoin donc lavé ce malaise
j'ai préféré limiter leur comportement
parce que si je parlais de cette
différence ça la rendrait plus réel et
ça me faisait déjà souffrir ça prenait
déjà trop de place c'était une erreur
mais ça n'a pas empêché de grandir et
j'arrive en primaire et
et en primaire je suis grand et je sais
enfin parler donc j'ai quelques amis et
plus je grandis dans cette primaire plus
je réalise que je m'intéresse pas trop à
mes amis en fait je m'ennuie avec eux je
suis pas je me sens pas aligné avec ce
qui laisse paraître de même et alors
alors je passe du temps seul mais ça me
va très bien je fais un peu notre
spéciaux je réfléchis un peu sur ma
situation et je me rends compte à huit
ans que je suis bloqué je suis bloqué
dans mes vingt kilomètres carrés entre
entre chez moi et mon école entre la
nécessité d'aller à l'école pour
apprendre les choses aient l'obligation
d'obéir à mes parents et surtout de
langage de mai
mais en dehors de ça ce que je développe
aussi chez moi c'est un rêve en fait je
rêve de sortir de ce blocage je rêve de
sortir de ces vingt kilomètres carrés où
je rêve d'être libre je rêve de pouvoir
faire de nouvelles choses tous les jours
pouvoir voyager en fait je rêve d'être
un oiseau je rêve d'être un pigeon est
de pouvoir voler
malheureusement ce rêve ne se réalise
pas où s'est pas encore réalisé et
j'arrive à saint thomas de villeneuve je
sais que certains connaissent dans la
salle merci d'ailleurs d'être venu et
et du coup je rencontre dans mon premier
jour de collège les 150 personnes avec
qui j'ai passé les sept prochaines
années de ma vie puisque c'est un
collège lycée
et alors je commence par passé les deux
premières années de mon collège tout
seul parce que c'est ce que j'avais cru
comprendre de ma primaires c'est que
j'aimais être seul et puis comme
j'allais pas vers les autres et que les
autres n'allez pas vers moi puisqu'il ne
me connaissait pas non plus bas ça se
passait très bien sauf qu'en quatrième
au quatrième je me rends compte que je
m'ennuie que je tourne trop en rond est
alors la seule chose qui est possible
pour moi puisque je suis toujours
bloqués dans mes vingt kilomètres carrés
même si l'école a changé c'est de parler
aux autres de rencontrer les autres pour
pouvoir faire de nouvelles choses
partager de nouvelles concessions que
c'est seulement seulement j'ai jamais eu
en fait cette envie d'avoir des amis et
alors alors je ne sais pas faire et 7
cette ignorance il entraîne un manque de
confiance en moi
donc ma solution c'est d'aller voir
grigoire dr la seule personne avec qui
je parlais de temps en temps et qui
était amené les peaux depuis la primaire
est en 4e j'ai mon premier groupe d'amis
je suis ami avec
avec grégoire et ses pattes on est on
parle de game of thrones de league of
legends toute la journée c'est une très
belle époque
seulement seulement je suis encore
curieux je vais encore rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes faire de nouvelles
choses partager de nouvelles
conversations et alors petit à petit
j'arrive à surpasser on manque de
confiance en moi qui étais niet cette
ignorance est alors en 1re j'ai fini par
avoir rencontré les 150 élèves de ma
promo et même je dirais même que j'étais
ami avec la majorité d'entre eux
est ce que je retiens de cette époque
c'est que si j'ai réussi c'est grâce à
l'introspection grâce à la remise en
question l'analyse de fait passer parce
que ce sont mes plus grandes forces
elles ont permis de comprendre et
d'appréhender mais différence en
primaire elles ont permis au début
collège de savoir ce que je voulais
faire elles m'ont permis au collège
lycée de me faire des amis et encore
aujourd'hui en fait elles me sont utiles
tous les jours ça m'aide à comprendre
l'image que je renvoie aux autres ça
m'aide à m'intégrer dans un nouveau
groupe intégré dans un nouvel
environnement et comprendre les règles
de cet environnement
et c'est pour ça que je vous incite vous
aussi ce soir faites le vous aussi
essayer de vous comprendre à travers la
compréhension de vos rêves connaître vos
rêves savoir avec qui vous voulez vivre
savoir ce que vous voulez faire parce
que ce qui est vraiment intéressant dans
l'introspection et en particulier
l'analyse de fait passer
c'est que on arrive à en tirer un
enseignement parce qu'on grandit de nos
expériences c'est vrai mais on grandit
vraiment lorsqu'on arrive à en tirer
quelque chose un enseignement justement
ou alors une compréhension plus profonde
des causes et conséquences de cet
événement sur nous sur les autres
et c'est pour ça que je vous incite à le
faire c'est pour que vous aussi vous
arriviez à retirer le plus possible de
chaque événement de votre vie et de
chaque événement que vous voyez que vous
viviez en fait effectivement et alors
vous pouvez brandir parce que plus on
grandit plus on sent bien non
ce qui est fantastique aussi c'est
qu'ensuite on peut échanger ses
différences on peut en parler on peut à
travers la communication parler de ce
qui est important pour nous par exemple
six mois en primaire j'avais bu palais à
mes parents de cette différence plutôt
que de la cacher peut-être qu'on aurait
pu ensemble trouver une solution en fait
est
là où je veux en venir c'est que la
communication s'est pas uniquement
parler c'est pas non plus parler pour
parler il faut avoir des choses à dire
il faut avoir des choses à expliquer à
partager et comme on est au minimum deux
dans une conversation il faut
nécessairement nécessairement savoir
écouter il faut s'intéresser à notre
interlocuteur prendre le temps se poser
et surtout quelque chose d'essentiel
aussi dans la communication c'est
d'accepter qu'on ne partage des dépenses
et des émotions et il faut nous aussi
qu'on accepte le fait qu'on peut les
partager puisque toutes les émotions que
ce soit de la joie de la jalousie la
haine du dégoût en fait elles sont
bonnes à partager pour se comprendre et
mieux comprendre les autres
est la clef je pense c'est de d'accepter
de comprendre d'aimer nos différence
grâce à l'introspection la remise en
question les états et ensuite d'exprimer
notre singularité exprimer nos
particularités vous les faire découvrir
aux autres en fait il faut les incarner
parce que lorsqu'on rencontre quelqu'un
on rencontre pas quelqu'un de nouveau
pour avoir les mêmes discussions que la
semaine dernière non ce qu'on veut faire
c'est rencontrer quelqu'un qui nous fait
une blague qu'on n'a jamais entendu et
et ça c'est beau mais de manière plus
sérieuse si quelqu'un nous apporte une
nouvelle vision des choses sur sur le
monde en parlant de ses expériences de
ces enseignements justement bah ça
élargit notre vision du monde et puis si
nous aussi on arrive à partager
sinon si on arrive à donner notre vision
du monde ça élargit la vision du monde
la personne en fait la communication
c'est essentiel et c'est très
intéressant parce que ça nous permet
d'élargir notre vision du monde et celle
des autres ensuite la communication on
peut on peut parler avec beaucoup de
gens mais le plus grand nombre de
personnes avec lequel on peut échanger
ses 8 milliards de personnes en théorie
puisque c'est toute la société puisque
chacun appartient à ce groupe là avant
il ya des gens qui vivent en majorité en
marginalité par nom de la société mais
c'est assez rare et puis la société
comme ça un concept assez compliqué
j'avais pensé de mettre une définition
mais comme c'est assez barbant si jamais
vous avez une notification sur votre
message si vous avez sur votre téléphone
si vous avez envie de vous moucher c'est
le moment on va tous ensemble lire une
définition
alors en philosophie le mot société
désigne à la fois un ensemble de
relations spontanée fondé sur des
rapports de dépendance est un ensemble
de relations fondées sur des accords
réciproque la société d'ergonomes
institué comme la bienséance et le
savoir vivre l'idée derrière la
définition c'est que 1 on ne peut pas
vivre sans les autres et que 2 l'as ptt
une relation influence grandement qui
nous sommes
de surcroît la société est là elle a un
troisième effet c'est que elle nous
éduque selon une certaine norme et ça ça
ça pourrait dire qu'elle gomme nos
différences ça pourrait nous faire
penser qu'elle tend à nous unit faire
musée puisque tout le monde vit dans
cette société ça veut dire uniformiser
nos besoins nos envies nos habits n'ose
pas favoris les boissons du samedi
et puis pourquoi pas nos enfants
et ça ça fait un peu peur mais
mais pour répondre à cette question et
pour réfléchir là dessus on a on a un
peu dead ce ken robinson
ken robinson
professeur d'université américaine il
défend lui l'idée que l'éducation
détruit la créativité éducation qui
provient la société puisque c'est elle
qui la propose d'être la créativité
créativité qui provient de nous mais
surtout des enfants selon monsieur ken
robinson puisque puisque les adultes ne
sont plus créatifs mais avant de se
pencher sur le négatif et sur pourquoi
les adultes ne serait plus créatifs je
pense qu'il est bon de se dire que si on
arrive à accepter nos différences à
comprendre qui nous sommes grâce à
l'introspection grâce à la remise en
question
et qu'on puisse ensuite changer le monde
dans un sens où il accepterait ces
différences ils les encouragerai même
unique pour nous comprendre en fait de
cette manière peut-être que ainsi vous
n'arriverez à rendre le monde plus
créatifs et permettre aux gens qui sont
dans qui vivent dans cette société de
cultiver leur créativité tout au long de
leur vie puisque un des effets de cette
société c'est quand même de gommer les
différences et donc
de réduire les possibilités pour ceux
qui souhaitent prendre un chemin
différent ou ceux qui souhaiteront en
tout cas prendre un chemin différent
et d'ailleurs moi je pense aussi que la
société l'a parfois du mal à évoluer je
pense que sur certains aspects certains
comportements elle se répète alors fait
les mêmes erreurs et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que tu as d'exister c'est pour
pouvoir faire partager des idées pour
que l'on fasse évoluer la société
qu'elle permette cette évolution alors
qu'elle l'accélère
mais ça ça me donne envie de vous poser
une question est ce que vous pensez
qu'on a du mal à sortir des sentiers
battus qu'on a du mal à être créatifs
parce que justement cette société nous
nous oppresse
je pense que en fait la solution allait
justement en nous et on a tout intérêt à
essayer à agir et d'ailleurs c'est la
question que je vais vous poser qu'avons
nous à perdre à essayer en fait qu'avons
nous à perdre on n'a rien à perdre et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que je fais devant
vous même si j'ai peur et d'ailleurs
c'est même pas une peur géo lui la
moitié de mon texte et je me suis trompé
et j'ai peur d'offenser quelqu'un j'ai
peur de dire des choses qui ne sont pas
ce que je pense je suis là j'essaye est
en fait c'est vraiment important c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que parce que
si j'essayais pas ça n'arrivera jamais
si je n'essaye pas jamais je pourrais
faire changer le monde dans un sens où
il acceptera il comprendra mais
différence
pour conclure comprendre les différences
c'est comprendre qu'ils ne sont pas
négatives comprendre qu'on ne peut pas
les faire disparaître et comprendre
qu'elle rendre ce monde plus riches
je parle beaucoup par expérience ce soir
mais je parle aussi avec une grande
conviction je crois tu réfléchir plus ou
nous mêmes face à l'introspection la
remise en question une star ça nous
permettrait de nous sentir mieux et puis
ça nous permettrait de faire évoluer la
société dans le sens qu'on veut merci à
tous pour votre temps et votre patience
je présiderai fo a parlé ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2 non